[Musique]
bonjour François Baayou bonour et merci
d'être là ce matin bienvenue vous étiez
ministre de l'Éducation quand la France
a manifesté fin 95 contre le plan Jupé
sur les retraites vous vous souvenez
j'imagine cette époque le scénario
peut-il recommencer aujourd'hui dans la
rue contre la loi de travail de Myriam
el comer
euh peut-être sans doute mais c'est pas
la véritable question la véritable
question c'est est-ce que la France peut
demeurer le pays de tous les blocages le
pays du blocage
éternel où aucun dialogue n'est
possible et chaque fois qu'une
proposition est avancée le pays dit non
descend dans la rue et se bloque c'est
il est impossible dans l'état où nous
sommes je sais pas si quelqu'un se
représente ce que signifie 6 millions de
chômeurs en réalité c'est le c'est le
vrai chiffre le vrai chiffre ou 6
million de chômeur avec leur famille qui
s'inquièteent et s'angoissent et avec
euh euh un système politique qui qui ne
marche plus ni dans la majorité ni dans
l'opposition euh avec une vie
parlementaire qui en réalité ne ne joue
pas son rôle est plétorique et ne joue
pas son rôle et tout ça ceux qui nous
écoutent euh s'arrache les cheveux ils
peuvent il il ne peut pas en être
autrement ils ont le sentiment qu'il n'y
a euh aucun aucune lumière au bout du
chemin et quand il y a pas de lumière au
bout du chemin un pays tombe c'est ça la
véritable question alors on est
aujourd'hui des manifestations il y en
aura davantage il y aura d'autres
journées qui sont prévues ouis si la
jonction s'effectue dans la rue entre
les jeunes les syndicats si si ça prend
François baayerou ça signifie quoi que
ce quinquena est terminé que le
gouvernement doit doit mettre la clé
sous la porte euh vous savez que mon
jugement est sévère sur le quinquena
depuis déjà de longs mois pour ne pas
dire
année pourquoi parce que euh ce qui est
frappant c'est que le le travail de
gouvernement euh au moins dans un de ces
éléments n'est pas fait qu'est-ce que
c'est le travail de gouvernement c'est
identifier des problèmes faire partager
cette identification à la société aux
citoyens il y a un travail de pédagogie
il y a un travail de
d'explication et ce qui me frappe par
exemple sur cette loi c'est que le
travail d'explication n'a pas été fait
et
euh c'est le président de la République
qui naturellement doit être en première
ligne pour faire le travail
d'explication il n'y est pas il laisse
le Premier ministre on a l'impression
d'un comment dirais-je d'un affrontement
sousterrain ou larvé et tout ceci est
est terriblement inquiétant et en effet
c'est la fin de cette période de 5
années qui est extrêmement difficile non
pas que l'opposition se porte beaucoup
mieux alors manuel Vals aurait évoqué
son éventuelle démission lors d'un dîner
de ministre c'est le Figaro qui
racontait ça ce que Najat Valo Belkassem
à votre place a démenti ici même hier
matin en dénonçant je la cite des bruit
de chiotte alors un il y a l'expression
elle vous a choqué du ministre de
l'éducation nationale non je suis pas
facilement chocable mais vous voyez bien
que ministre de l'éducation nationale ça
a une petite responsabilité dans son
expression ou une grande responsabilité
parce que il y a une exemplarité de
cette
fonction que j'ai pour ma part beaucoup
aimé ça c'est la première chose la
deuxième chose j'ai bien écouté elle a
pas démenti madame Valo
belcassem elle a dit
on ne devrait pas répéter ce genre de
chos ce qui à mon sens est passé en tout
cas à mon oreille pour une confirmation
et je comprends très bien que le premier
ministre se pose cette question comprend
très bien que le premier ministre qui
considère qu'il y a qu'il propose ou
qu'il avance un texte très important
pour lui-même disent si ce texte est
retiré ou vidé de son contenu
naturellement je ne peux que envisager
de me retirer c'est à peu près ce que
j'ai Ret tenu de ce vrai faux démenti
alors vous évoquez le marasme de la vie
politique nationale vous avez vu ça et
de 10 natalie cuscorisé est entré hier
soir officiellement en campagne pour la
primaire cette fois-ci à droite on parle
même de Michel liomarie bon Nicolas
Sarkozi l'issans lettre on serait à 11 à
12 qu'est-ce qui se passe dans la
famille politique de l'opposition si le
ridicule tua il y aurait beaucoup de
gens en danger parce que la
multiplication des candidatures diverses
et variées euh euh qui pour un grand
nombre d'entre elles n'ont pas la
crédibilité de la fonction
présidentielle parce que au bout de ce
chemin qu'est-ce qu'il y a il y a une
chose qui est tout de même importante et
précieuse c'est que il faut qu'il y ait
un président de la République en France
en capacité de remplir sa fonction et
avec une majorité dans le pays dans le
pays je parle même pas dans les
assemblées une majorité dans le pays qui
lui permettent d'être soutenu compris et
d'entraîner les grands chos ch et donc
cette vous savez que j'ai jamais pensé
beaucoup de bien de la primaire mais
enfin de cette idée de primaire il
suffit de voir ce qui se passe aux
États-Unis et cette idée de primaire à
mon sens c'est risqué elle pousse à la
surenchère et elle pousse à la
multiplication des candidatures qui
comme des champignons après la
pluie poussent explosent et ne dureront
pas très longtemps mais ça n'ajoute pas
à la crédibilité de la politique avec
François Baou candidat si Alain Jup n va
pas vous l'avez déjà déjà dit pas
vraiment en fait ben écoutez nous serons
ensemble vous voyez bien la situation on
va pas se retrouver dans les mêmes dans
la même configuration qu'au 2è tour de
2012 il faut il faudrait dans ce cas-là
alors que je souhaite que Alain Jupé
puisse offrir une nouvelle manière de
gouverner en France mais il faudrait
évidemment dans ce cas-là de nouveaux
choix pour le pays
mais je veux vous dire ceci je me tiens
à des milliers de kilomètres de ces
histoires de primaire de d'affrontement
dans un
bocal qui je vous l'ai dit déconsidère
un peu la politique comme en tout cas
j'y crois MERCI BEAUCOUP François BA en
direct avec
nous